When the new Mac Mini came out in October,
it made a lot of buzz because Apple packed
much better hardware than anyone was expecting.
The RAM is once again user-upgradable, even
though it's not easy, it has a very impressive
4 thunderbolts 3 ports, the option for 10-gigabit
ethernet, and up to a 6 core i7 processor.
It was basically a Mac Mini Pro.
The six-core i7 CPU outperformed any iMac
back then, since they were limited to 4 cores,
and with the promise of optimized eGPU support
with Mojave’s new prefer eGPU feature, it
was a fantastic value!
And we’d still recommend everyone to get
the $1,100 Mac Mini over the $800 Mac Mini
because you get the 6-core CPU and a 256GB
SSD, which is the least we’d recommend on
any computer.
And now that it’s getting close to a year
later, has the Mac Mini lived up to the potential
we first saw in it?
No.. and I’ll tell you exactly why in just
a minute.
There are a couple of things that are really
special about the Mac Mini, and the biggest
thing is the extensive variety of I/O, with
4 Thunderbolt 3 ports, 2 USB 3 ports, the
option of 10GB Ethernet, and HDMI.
You literally cannot get this much I/O on
any other mac other than the $5,000 iMac Pro.
It even allows you to swap out the RAM yourself
and save about $550 on a 64GB kit compared
to Apple’s $1,000 64GB RAM upgrade by using
the link in the description below.
The Mac Mini packs a ton of performance for
the compact size, and the most important thing
is that it runs MacOS and will continue to
get free macOS updates for years to come.
Because of the compact size, you’re definitely
not getting the full performance out of the
six-core CPU because it does throttle down
a little bit compared to its potential in
a machine with better cooling, but it still
performs very well.
The only major downside of the Mac Mini is
that it doesn’t pack a dedicated graphics
chip, but that may not be a bad thing if you’re
someone like a photographer or programmer
who literally doesn’t need any extra graphics
performance at all.
But if you’re looking to do some video editing
or 3D animation work, you’re definitely
gonna want to hook up an eGPU.
We recommend the Razer Core X eGPU enclosure
with a Vega 64 graphics card for around $700,
but you can definitely buy an RX 580 instead
and bring that down to around $500.
In our previous testing from a few months
ago, we noticed that it shot graphics performance
through the roof, so it seems like an awesome
deal for a very capable machine.
We recently got a new video editing in our
office, and she’s been using a Mac Mini
that we got in as a loaner for a video as
a temporary editing setup because we already
have everything we need for it, including
a 4K monitor, a wireless mouse, an old Apple
keyboard and an eGPU that we used for previous
videos.
However, even though we already have everything
we need to make this Mac Mini shine, we’ll
be sending it back and won’t be getting
another one for long-term use.
Here’s why.
The iMac has just been updated for 2019, and
even the 21.5” 4K iMacs now come with the
same 6-core processors, and you can eve get
8-core i9 processors on the MacBooks and 5K
iMacs.
And while it may seem that the Mac Mini is
a much better deal, now that the iMacs have
been updated, everything that’s bundled
in for that price makes it a MUCH better value
than the Mac Mini, even if you have to spend
a little bit more.
First off, the Mac Mini comes with nothing.
No mouse.
No Keyboard.
And No display.
While the iMac comes with all of that.
That’s $100 for the keyboard.
$79 for the mouse.
And the best part is the 5K display, which
is one of the best displays you can find on
the market, featuring incredible color accuracy,
brightness and super sharp resolution.
The standalone LG version of that display
was priced at $1,300.
So if you add all of that up, the iMac is
such a better deal, and it comes with dedicated
graphics already.
The problem with getting an eGPU on the Mac
Mini is that you lose a lot of performance
efficiency because the data has to go through
the Thunderbolt 3 cable, so a much more powerful
Vega 64 graphics card ends up being not that
much faster than the Radeon Pro 580X in the
5K iMac.
Now of course, if you don’t need graphics
performance, the Mac Mini starts to make a
lot of sense.
But if you’re a photographer who is going
to buy a very color accurate 4K display for
a few hundred dollars.
It actually makes more sense to just pay $500
more to get a very color accurate P3 display,
mouse, keyboard and 560X graphics, which is
what comes in the $2800 MacBook Pro.
Now if you’re looking for a bit more performance
than that with the i7 six-core processor,
512GB SSD and you already have your own mouse,
keyboard, and monitor, you’ll spend $2,000
if you get an eGPU with the RX 580 graphics.
For just $400 more, you can get the top-end
5K iMac which comes with peripherals, much
better graphics performance due to it being
mora efficient inside the machine, easy access
to RAM with double the RAM slots, and of course,
that gorgeous and color accurate 5K display.
Even if you spend more and get a Vega 64 graphics
card in the eGPU, in many cases, the 580X
in the iMac will perform just as well or even
better and you don’t need to have a large
and loud box sitting on your desk.
Now if Apple upgraded the Mac Mini with an
8-core processor, or if eGPU performance was
better, it would make a lot more sense.
But at this time, we would honestly suggest
almost everyone to just save up a bit more
cash and go for the new iMac.
The experience will be much better and you’ll
get more performance for the cash.
Now we told you that there are a few cases
where the Mac Mini still makes a lot of sense.
The biggest one is if you are using it as
a server or in other cases you don’t even
need a display most of the time, just a nice
and small computer.
The Mac Mini would be a perfect option for
this.
The second is if you really need more than
two thunderbolts 3 ports, which you can’t
get on the new iMac, except for the iMac Pro.
Along with that, if you need 10GB ethernet
and you don’t want to use up a Thunderbolt
3 port for an adapter, it’s only a $100
option on the Mac Mini.
Lastly, the Mac Mini makes sense if you don’t
need a good graphics card, say for photo editing
or coding, and you already have a display
and peripherals that you want to use.
For most people though, even in this scenario,
we would highly suggest giving the 4K or 5K
iMac a shot, its seriously amazing once you
try it.
We’ve been using the 5K iMac for years,
and we can’t go back to average 4K monitors.
The Mac Mini isn’t a bad machine by any
means, and it still has some good uses, but
almost a year later, it doesn’t offer the
same value that it had at launch.
The processors are no longer special, considering
that the new MacBook Pro and 5K iMac now offer
8-cores, and eGPU performance is nowhere near
where we thought it would be.
We really hope that Apple won’t forget about
this tiny powerhouse and will keep updating
it with new processors and better cooling,
but for now, we think most people will have
a much better experience with an iMac.